il ya deux sortes d'homosexuels ya
d'abord ceux qui sont malades et ceux
qui font ça pour de l'argent alors c'est
déjà des jeux différents je considère
qu'en mai
malade et fou comme les fausses en
connaissance vous les comprenez vous les
admins les maoris j'ai des amis qui sont
comme ça et comment jugez vous les
hommes qui aiment les hommes est-ce que
c'est pas normal c'est un risque war
tard indique dans ma maison il y en a ça
vous gêne je ne sais pas si c'est vrai
je me pose la question si c'est exact je
vien députée une femme comme n'est plus
tellement vous pensez que tous les
sont des se prostituent
pourquoi il le ferait alors pour ce
qu'ils valent à moi je regarde bon enfin
et ça leur plaît qu'est ce que vous
pensez des pdg vous aimez pas pourquoi
j'ai pas sauf que c'est les
je sais pas j'ai pas eu autour du car
franchement bail
d'égalité ce sont les mêmes droits pour
tous quel que soit son sexe
l'orientation c'est le droit de pouvoir
se marier d'adopter pour les fonds et en
décide ainsi
c'est l'engagement 31 de la campagne
présidentielle de françois hollande est
l'une des priorités du début de son
quinquennat
après les pays bas la belgique l'espagne
ou encore le danemark la france s'empare
du mariage homosexuel une réforme
emblématique pour la gauche mais rejetée
par une majorité de la droite
le sénat a choisi jean-pierre michel
comme rapporteur du texte
il y à présent cet élu socialiste a déjà
été le rapporteur de la loi sur le pacs
cet ancien magistrat s'est toujours
battu pour les droits des homosexuels
j'ai en moi une espèce de passion pour
l'égalité alors je sais bien qu'elle
égalité n'est pas n'est pas naturel que
tous ne sont pas tous égaux
parce que nous ne sont pas de la même
manière parce que nous avons des
familles qui nous permet de faire plus
d'études
vous avez dans des milieux différents
donc nous ne sont pas égaux c'est vrai
mais je pense que le rôle du législateur
et notamment que c'est le rôle des
socialistes de prendre toutes les
mesures possibles pour réduire ces
inégalités et pour réduire dans la rue
la contestation prend forme
le collectif la manif pour tous trouvant
frigide barjot l'égérie médiatique qui
lui faisait défaut
cet humoriste atypique chroniqueuse
mondaine et fervente catholique devient
la porte parole des opposants au texte
13 janvier 2013 julien et cécile
manifeste pour la première fois de leur
vie d'enfer fait déjà au travers
trouver un nombre de traversées membre
d'alliance vite à une association fondée
par christine boutin contre l'avortement
et l'euthanasie
ils sont opposés au projet du
gouvernement bonne manif cécile est
conseillère municipale à fontenay le
fleury dans les yvelines ce qui la gêne
dans ce projet de loi c'est l'adoption
par les couples homosexuels ou ne leur
ne vient pas pas une dame en valeur
donnée deux papas ou deux mamans et ça
ne semble pas être le bien profond de
l'enfant qui a besoin de s'identifier à
un père ou une mère
ce jour là le champ de mars est envahi
de drapeaux roses et bleus une bataille
des chiffres va opposer les anti mariage
homosexuel au gouvernement entre 340
milles selon la préfecture de police et
800 mille manifestants selon les
organisateurs vont être comptabilisés
face à cette opposition qui s'exprime de
plus en plus fort les partisans du
projet de loi descendre dans la rue à
leur tour au delà du mariage gay c'est
bien de france qui vont apparaître et
deux conceptions de la famille qui vont
s'affronter pour tous les enfants
d'aller c'est la première fois qu'on
manifeste parce qu'on a été choqués de
voir qu'à quinze jours autant de
personnes dans les rues qui
manifestaient contre notre liberté notre
on les laisse choisir leur orientation
sexuelle leur choix de vie leurs
familles
à l'assemblée nationale les députés ont
commencé l'examen du texte l'opposition
entend créer le débat dans l'hémicycle
cinq mille amendements sont déposées le
projet de loi prévoit le mariage et
l'adoption pour les couples homosexuels
il n'est pas question d'autoriser la
procréation médicalement assistée ou la
gestation pour autrui
c'est pourtant le chiffon rouge que va
agiter la droite pendant les cent dix
heures de discussion dans l'hémicycle à
l'article et vous me fournissait
l'occasion de réaffirmer réaffirmé
formellement ici que ce gouvernement
s'est déjà prononcée et confirme qu'il
est absolument opposé à la gpa et qu'il
ne l'ouvrira pas les débats vont révéler
l'autorité et la détermination de
christiane taubira
après des jours et des nuits passées
dans l'hémicycle merci à tous pour ses
jours et ses nuits passées ensemble pour
c'est pour ces sourires pour ses reer
pour ces confrontations aussi conviction
contre conviction ce projet de loi nous
a conduits à penser autrui à consentir à
l'altérité pensée autrui disait emmanuel
levinas relève de l'irréductible
inquiétude pour l'autre
c'est ce que nous avons fait tout le
monde se débat
après l'assemblée nationale c'est au
tour du sénat d'être saisi le sénat a
choisi de prendre son temps et
d'entendre toutes les opinions sur ce
texte
quarante audition menée par jean pierre
michel et jean pierre sueur
le président de la commission des lois
les auditions qui vont permettre aux
sénateurs de se faire leur propre
opinion
la plupart dessinateurs ont une position
très arrêtées qui est dépendante de
l'orientation du vent partis politiques
bon voilà mais quand on les interroge un
peu plus pour certains ça paraît
beaucoup plus nuancé et donc pense que
avec des informations comme celles
connues hier encore aujourd'hui ou
demain ou gerra peut-être que certains
sénateurs pourrait soit d'un côté ou de
l'autre
surtout je pense surtout à ceux qui
seront contre par principe se détacher
de son compte propre ainsi p arrivées à
une abstention
vous devez être plus positif dans les
débats anthropologues sociologues
psychiatres religieux juriste et membre
de la société civile vont se succéder à
la tribune pendant plusieurs semaines
très vite il apparaît que ce n'est pas
tant le mariage qui fait débat mais
plutôt la question de l'adoption par des
couples homosexuels très bien comme
m'écouter bon ça fait très plaisir
la première trouver le sénat va avoir un
rôle très particulier dans la capacité
qu'il aura à démêler cette caisse et
malentendus sur la filiation qu'on
comprend mieux après après deux trois
mois de débats qu'on ne les comprenaient
au début donc j'attends beaucoup du
sénat est une assemblée dont je sais
depuis longtemps que c'est un endroit où
on débat les questions vraiment au fond
alors pour montrer à quel point cette
question fait débat
je citerai parmi les très nombreux les
très nombreuses personnes que j'aurais
pu citer un organisme qui est tout à
fait capital l'union nationale des
associations familiales qui dans un
document qu'elle a rendues publiques en
octobre indique ceci ouvrir l'ensemble
de l'adoption aux couples de même sexe
pose en particulier la question de
l'adoption plénière alors qu'un enfant
ne peut naître que d'un homme et d'une
femme
l'accès éventuel à l'adoption plénière
remettrait
riddick mans en cause cette réalité
laissant croire qu'il est possible de
naître de deux personnes de même sexe
j'ai cité ce texte pour montrer et
énoncer désigner un malentendu car bien
entendu personne parmi les défenseurs du
projet n'imagine de laisser croire qu'un
enfant peut naître de deux femmes ou
deux hommes et qu'il n'est pas question
à travers l'adoption plénière de
remettront juridiquement en cause cette
réalité
j'ai les pédopsychiatres l'adoption par
des couples de même sexe fait débat un
enfant peut-il être élevé par deux
parents de même sexe
les avis divergent faut savoir que pour
un enfant ça veut strictement rien dire
un parent de même sexe deuxièmement pour
un enfant un père qui n'engendre pas une
mère qui n'engendre pas soit d'un point
de vue réelle soit d'un point de vue
symbolique comme on l'a vu dans
l'adoption de la mp ça ne peut pas
fonctionner parce qu'un enfant ne peut
pas se dire issus de deux hommes ou deux
femmes
vous parlez de l'absolue nécessité
d'avoir un père et une mère ça me
surprendre par la psychanalyse parce qu'
est-ce que c'est pas plus important
d'avoir une fonction paternelle et une
fonction maternelle qui n'est pas
forcément assumée par quelqu'un du sexe
masculin pour la fonction paternelle et
pour un enfant il ya ainsi de suite fin
moi je je suis un père qui fait beaucoup
de fonction maternelle
comment dire le paternel de la femme ne
sera jamais le même que le paternel de
l'homme le maternelle de l'homme sera
jamais le même que le maternel de la
femme c'est à dire que au delà de cette
fonction il ya quelque chose qui dépasse
ces fonctions là qui est l'être propre
du père et l'autre propre de la mer et
là on a vu que l'enfant différent si
cela tout simplement parce que oui un
père ne sera jamais une mère comme les
autres et que et que cela dépasse
l'histoire de la fonction le fait de
descendre les poubelles et faire la
vaisselle
cela n'a rien à voir
il y à des situations concrètes
effectivement donc la situation concrète
c est ce qu il est possible est pensable
que dans notre société
un enfant qui soit élevée par qui que ce
soit n'est pas référence aux deux sexes
qui existent dans la société ça il me
semble que tenir un tel discours et dire
non il n'aurait pas la référence c'est
absolument absurde
est ce que on considère que cette
référence aux deux sexes est ce qu'elle
doit être dans le cadre de la famille
nucléaire
ou alors est ce qu'elle peut être de
façon plus élargie c'est ça la question
pragmatique qu'il faut se poser une
famille nucléaire ou une famille peut se
concevoir de façon tout à fait élargi
combien d'entre nous ici on une idée de
leur famille qui ne se résume pas
uniquement à leur père à leur mère rêve
chez les juristes le débat est aussi
animée certains pensent que la loire met
en cause le droit de la filiation est la
base même du droit civil
d'autres pensent au contraire que la loi
doit suivre les évolutions de la société
la question que se joue ici c'est la
question des liens de droit et plus
particulier les liens familiaux qui sont
fondés sur deux rapports de rapports qui
sont le rapport de l'alliance qui repose
sur le mariage et la filiation
c'est à dire le rapport biologique ce
que je voulais dire c'est que ce lien de
la filiation et du mariage ils sont
indétachable au départ donc ici on n'a
ni en avant le lien biologique la vérité
biologique et vous accorder le mariage
aux couples homosexuels pour des
filiations qui seront forcément fictive
puisqu'il ne progrès pas entre eux alors
bouleversé à ce point tout le droit de
la filiation
parce que vous accordez le mariage à des
couples homosexuels qui n'entendent
quand même pas une majorité de français
je pense que c'est extrêmement grave et
au moins si vous le faites prenez le
temps et réfléchissent et en même temps
vous pouvez pas dissocier et dire on
verra plus tard ce qu'on a mis sous le
tapis en le réduire à ça franchement je
suis venu vous dire ne faites pas ça
c'est trop grave
j'ai un peu le sentiment que c'est
développe aujourd'hui une dimension plus
de type biologique
la revendication de l'accès aux origines
la place du des génies terre enfin vous
voyez je pense qu'il ya aujourd'hui un
discours qui tend plutôt à dire on est
allé trop loin dans la dimension
volontaires volontariste et la filiation
dont rêve non quand même à une dimension
quelque peu biologique dont j'essaye de
démontrer le contraire mais je pense
qu'il n'y a pas des liens plus forts et
des liens plus stable et pour moi des
liens plus sûr en tant que juriste de
liens d'engagement des responsabilités
que les liens qui part dé la volonté et
non pas d'une imposition de type
biologique
je trouve que l'évolution est
souhaitable puisque si on fait rentrer
d'un institution dans la loi des gens
qui n'étaient pas originellement dans la
loi les juifs où est passée marié les
protestants pouvait pas se marier
les femmes étaient soumises aux hommes
les enfants nés hors mariage n'avait pas
de droit donc tout l'histoire du mariage
l'histoire d'un élargissement d'une
institution qui a inclus qui n'était pas
une institution exclusive sur le plan du
droit
je trouve que l'on est en train de
bouleverser droit de la filiation sans
vraiment le dire est qu'on va faire une
impasse juridique est d'ailleurs
beaucoup de spécialistes du droit civil
vous avez entendu peu de spécialistes du
droit civil qui était favorable à ce
texte tel qu'il est est ce qu'il a été
improvisée dès l'instant où on touche au
code civil est bien placé pour le savoir
parce qu'à l'époque du pacs était pareil
on voit que tout tout ce qu'ils
enseignent côte suivi tout ce qui parle
du code civil les magistrats les mettra
de la chancellerie sont absolument
bouleversés voilà qu'après il faudrait
qu'ils s'y fassent et qu'ils entraînent
une nouvelle règle
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui nous recevons
l'ensemble des représentants des cultes
depuis deux heures de l'après midi 14
heures jusqu'à fin aux juristes
succèdent les représentants des grandes
religions qui sont majoritairement
contre le projet de loi
le grand rabbin de france gilles
bernheim a écrit un texte qui a marqué
les esprits contre le projet de loi
je suis un homme de la bible comme peut
l'être le chrétien le musulman est aussi
mais de manière différente puisque le
livre n'est pas écrit pour lui la bible
lorsqu'elle interdit formellement
l'homosexualité et notament expressément
le mot sécurité masculines et féminines
elle n'en parle pas mais ça c'est un
autre sujet comment est ce que je me
comporte devant vous avec ce texte
évidemment avec un tel texte
si vous demandez aux bibliste juifs ou
chrétiens
mais est ce que tu es pour est ce que tu
es contre le mariage des homosexuels
qu'est ce qu'ils voulaient qu'il amorce
comme réflexion l'homosexualité étant
strictement interdite dans la bible il
va vous n'imaginez pas un instant qu'il
va vous dire mais le mariage des
homosexuels
non seulement je l'autorisent mais je
vais lui donner un cadre juridique les
dirait qu'à la question est anachronique
la première remarque je voudrais faire
c'est une question qui peut paraître un
peu byzantine mais qu'il ne l'est pas
c'est la question de savoir si la
différence sexuelle est une inégalité la
différence sexuelle n'est pas une
inégalité qu'il ya dans l'existence
humaine
il ya des données de fait les
différences de fait qui ne donne pas un
droit juridique à devenir comme les
autres c'est le mariage n'est pas un
bien comme un public qu'on peut
distribuer comme des sucettes la sortie
de l'école donc ça n'est pas c'est pas
faire injustice ou injure que de dire
que le mariage a une fonction à une
finalité propre dans la société qui est
de structurer d'organiser la
transmission entre les générations et
l'éducation des enfants ils croyons les
chrétiens on ne faisait pas un besoin
d'accueil en un devoir d'accueillir
toutes les personnes vous pas les
rejeter
en dehors de la sphère c'est ce qui se
fait aujourd'hui est donc vraiment je ne
comprends pas à quoi ça me faisait me
laisse complètement pantois en plus je
veux être un peu méchant je dirais que
rien dans l'énergie n'a pas mérité ce
qu'ils disent rien et surtout et surtout
pas ce qu'on appelle la famille le père
etc adoptifs comme chacun sait dans la
mer
en font-elles récents vierge par quels
moyens mais ma vie est entre les
auditions d'experts psychiatres ou de
juriste jean pierre michel auditionnent
ce couple de retraités après avoir lu
leur témoignage dans un journal annick
et rené était producteur de lait dans la
région nantaise
il y a vingt ans ils ont découvert
l'homosexualité de terry leur petite
dernière ils ont fait depuis un long
cheminement avant de l'accepter
on est en couple marié donc 80 ans il
est la quatrième des ris de veau
sexuelle elle a 36 ans vous a fait
pratiquement 20 ans
qu'on a découvert son homosexualité
et puis avec nîmes on n'y connaissez
rien du tout ah ben moi je croyais que
c'était un choix pervers c'est bon par
ignorance sûr mais je crois pas je
n'étais pas mouffok je crois pas au
mieux alors j'en étais à ce stade alors
déjà
mais je me disais mon enfant est pas
terrible n'est pas comme ce qu'on voit à
la télé là non c'est pas possible
oui parce que dans quelques années très
dures avec quelqu'un ma lune une année
particulièrement ou vraiment on se
demande dès le matin comment on allait
la retrouver un c'est sur les besoins de
l'écologie oui oui oui mais ça n'a pas
suffi non plus je crois que vraiment
l'acceptation le regard des autres est
très dur très dur et nous a fait mal
il a été retrouvé un courrier que le
drame était fait un séjour en possession
elle arrêtée elle a été récupérée juste
à temps mais veut briller jusqu'au 16
mai
homosexuel et vivent très bien leur eux
ont fait part en dedans forme sexuelle
est bien heureux pareil ce qui les prix
négatif pour les uns comme pour les
autres c'est le regard des autres sa
quiétude
sinon les biens
et le regard des autres est parfois
difficile à supporter deux mois après
leur audition au sénat
annick et rené rendent visite à leur
fille chérie et à sa compagne bea près
de toulouse au lendemain d'une
manifestation des opposants ils sont
inquiets
j'ai la famille morantin le doute
commence à s'installer ici le texte ne
passait pas effectivement une fesse sur
tous comme ça la fin de tous poussé
aussi fort ils viennent avec des enfants
une post des barricades ont fait c'est
un peu excessif pour un projet qui est
pas une question de vie ou un jour ça
c'est impressionnant quand même j'espère
qu'elle
j'espère que le gouvernement va lâcher
quoi moi ça m'inquiète beaucoup je
m'inquiète beaucoup je me dis qu'il ne
tient pas à pas grand chose en fait
une société qui meeting qui autorise des
choses et qu'il avance est une société
qui régresse
pour terry les débats autour du projet
de loi font ressurgir les fantômes du
passé
c'est complètement renfermée je
n'arrivais pas à leur dire ça j'étais
pieman j'ai été un petit peu entre
guillemets conditionné dans cette cette
religion qui est catholicisme avec avec
l'église et pour moi c'était pas
compatibles du tout et je le demandais
où est ce que vous allez aller quand je
mourrai je ne pourrais pas être reconnu
comme personne et comme étant une
personne à part entière
je me suis je me suis enfermé dans ma
bulle romont monde
la mère elle m'a dit parce que j'étais
effondrée 1 j'étais vraiment effondré
j'en ai pas l'agepi je ne savais pas
qu'elle allait être sérieux et sa
réaction j'avais vraiment peur mon avis
ou et pierre reste toujours fier de ce
que tu es de toi il m'a laissé un cahier
pour pouvoir exprimer tout ce
cheminement finalement tout ce que
j'avais sur le coeur et je crois que
c'est mais c'est une vingtaine de pages
que les écrits d'un coup d'un seul parce
que j'avais
avait beaucoup sur le coeur à dire et
donc je leur ai donné le cahier juste
après pour qu'ils puissent lire et puis
je le lis souvent c'est moi
tél
mais tous les parents n'acceptent pas
toujours l'homosexualité de leur enfant
l'association le refuge à paris héberge
des jeunes rejetés par leur famille à
cause de leur homosexualité
pour le rapporteur du texte au sénat ce
projet de loi a aussi pour but de faire
reculer l'homophobie
moi j'ai 18 ans je suis hébergé depuis
trois semaines je suis en contact avec
lui refuse depuis quatre mois déclarant
ça se passait mal depuis un an et demi
j'étais placé au foyer g est à la rue
chez des amis et c'est un tort ici un
problème si on a aussi consulté
c'était juste ça c'était les accidents
pas de l'homosexualité en fait ils vont
ceux qui acceptent mais en fait quand il
voit et le mi6 utc nom d une maladie
ouais moi je soutiens que quand on nie
pas des citoyens les d'avoir les mêmes
droits que les autres citoyens
en france cette grisaille s intègre
quels qu'ils soient
tout ce temps là parce qu'ils ont fait
l'objet d'un rejet familial et jeu parce
que ce qu'il faut dire pour appeler à la
responsabilité des parents et je crois
que quelles que puissent être les
d'exception qu'on peut avoir qu'un
nouveau en france ont effectué le peut
le comprendre
je ne pense pas qu'il faut je suis là au
sénat jean-pierre michel retrouve le
député erwann binet rapporteur de la loi
à l'assemblée nationale je suis là
objectif examiner le texte dans le
détail afin de pointer du doigt les
améliorations que le sénat pourrait
apporter par rapport à la version de
l'assemblée nationale après avoir
examiné le texte en détail il apparaît
et avoir entendu un certain nombre
d'auditions
il apparaît que le sénat devra apporter
un certain nombre d'amendements
j'aime bien ce moment parce que le coût
en scène sur le passage de relais loup
on confie au sénat le travail qu'il faut
faire l'assemblée mais en même temps
avec la volonté qui est la mienne de
défendre un peu les a beaucoup pas que
j'ai déposée ou auquel je vais
commission a donné un avis favorable
et puis peut-être de discuter sur
quelques points techniques qui ont été
révélés assez tardivement ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que le débat à l'assemblée
était quand même très très vif très très
dur et qu' il ya eu de forme
d'improvisation en séance qui est
d'ailleurs le gouvernement lui-même dit
que certaines
chose qu'ils ont été adoptés mérite
d'être mieux dû creuser le rapporteur du
texte au sénat souhaite modifier la
version de l'assemblée nationale ceux
des points juridiques à la marge
mes chers collègues nous allons ouvrir
notre cette séance je vous remercie
d'être venus très nombreux
signe de l'intérêt qui est le vôtre pour
le texte sur le mariage pour tous
mais ce qui cristallise le plus les
tensions chez les sénateurs alors qu'ils
interrogent la ministre sur son projet
de loi
c'est la question de la filiation et de
la pma alors merci madame benbassa
monsieur lecerf questions portent
effectivement également sur la pme la
gpa qui sont un peu si vous voulez ce qu
est l alsace lorraine entre 71 et 1914
c'est à dire à y penser toujours n'en
parler jamais donc ce qui me gêne
beaucoup si vous voulez ce qui fait que
moi je suis de ceux qui n'ont vraiment
aucune hostilité bien au contraire
house mariage entre personnes du même
sexe mais il me semble que si j'accepte
à la fois le mariage et l'adoption
inéluctablement selon effectivement des
des autorités en matière juridique d'eau
tendances différentes
je serai amené à accepter la pma la gpa
par simple convenance c'est à dire une
certaine forme de marchandisation des
corps que je refuse alors comment
peut-on faire mais d'amener ministre
pour que cet engrenage de semaine en
haute pour répondre à votre question sur
l'engrenage il y à des traitements
différenciés entre l'assistance médicale
à la procréation et la gestation pour
autrui
à partir du moment où la gestation pour
autrui c'est la position du gouvernement
très clair très ferme demeure un
principe de l'indisponibilité du corps
et d'ordre public
c'est le barrage à l'engrenage c'est le
barrage à l'engrenage
mes chers collègues nous en sommes
arrivés à notre dernière audition
publique et je dois vous dire que le
cette dernière audition eux est
l'occasion pour moi de redire combien
nous avons pris plaisir à toutes ses
auditions en tout cas plaisir
intellectuel et combien ces auditions
nous ont apporté au terme des auditions
le collectif la manif pour tous menée
par frigide barjot demande à être
entendu à son tour les j'obtiens michel
refuse de les recevoir
il a fait 40 heures d'audition tien minh
aujourd'hui on est plus grande chez nous
pour les entendre la deuxième raison
c'est une raison de fond fait que je
considère que cette pseudo association
créée de toutes pièces pour les besoins
de la cause
noren apporter aux auditions quand ils
se passent très sérieuse et que donc je
n'ai pas souhaité l'entendre voilà au
surplus c'est à dire que les
manifestations que ce collectif organisé
me laisse beaucoup à désirer
choqués d'un certain nombre de termes
qui ont été employés par cette pièce
d'homophobie attentes qui ne veut pas
dire son nom mais qui existent pour
motiver son refus jean pierre michel
écrit une lettre au collectif la manif
pour tous aux yeux du sénateur frigide
barjot et le collectif n'ont aucune
légitimité
dans sa lettre il qualifie la manif pour
tous d'homophobe frigide barjot décide
alors d'assigner jean pierre michel en
diffamation si monsieur michel n'avait
pas envoyé cette lettre infamante voilà
et diffamatoires eh ben on ne serait pas
là si monsieur hollande et son
gouvernement n'avait pas imposer cette
loi excessive
nous ne serions pas dans l'armée
frigide barjot et la manif pour tous
réclament 6000 euros de dommages et
intérêts finalement le tribunal déboute
les requérants
pendant ce temps au sénat avant l'examen
en séance publique la commission des
lois examine le rapport de jean pierre
michel le texte est adopté avec deux
voix de l'opposition
ce débat il n'a pas été un débat où les
gens ont voté seulement par rapport à
leur appartenance à un parti
ce n'est pas un secret que deux élus de
l'ump ont voté pour le texte et que deux
élus de radicaux de gauche n'ont pas
pris part au vote
il ya une évolution des moeurs qu'on le
veuille ou pas et vous savez un
magistrat au magistrat jouer avec cette
phrase que j'ai retenu la meilleure loi
est celle qui entérine l'évolution des
moeurs
on peut pas aujourd'hui accepté de dire
rien ne s'est passé est obligé de
l'accepter et donc il faut que la loi
sada et en plus la france n'est pas
seule dans le monde et elle est obligée
de tenir quant au talent et pas ou je te
faire pareil mais elle ne peut pas ne
pas en tenir compte
mais la mobilisation des opposants au
projet de loi ne faiblit pas dans les
yvelines
julien et cécile se prépare pour une
nouvelle manifestation
cette fois ils emmènent leurs trois
garçons pour des listes ou soigneuse des
gens qui montrent le bout d'un quart
parce qu'ils ont payé un aller-retour
l'homosexualité pour moi n'est n'est pas
le n'est pas forcément fait l'enjeu du
débat en fait je pense que
l'homosexualité c'est entre guillemets
ainsi je peux dire c'est l'arbre qui
cache la forêt en fait je pense que tout
le débat qui en qui est en jeu dans ce
projet de loi c'est tout ce qui concerne
la filiation la gérer à la pma et que
pour pour empêcher le débat et pour dire
non on utilise le terme homophobie comme
on utilise le terme rapidement fait
c'est parce que en fait ça va dans les
deux sens dès que enfin voilà donc on
utilise le terme homophobie a comme ça
on ne parle pas surtout on ne réfléchit
pas on utilise des termes gpa pma que
beaucoup de français ne comprennent pas
puisqu'il voit pas très bien ce que ça
veut dire et je pense que c'est va là
c'est une façon de nier le débat et pour
moi c'est vraiment une négation de la
démocratie
j'ai mon groupe et ya le tien et dans
mon groupe va y avoir le second corps si
on inscrit quinze personnes mais on sait
pas encore si c'est non mais pourquoi je
tenais à la grande armée
lamy
mais fort de la civilisation concept de
société vend de la société française en
faisant valoir que c'était ce qu'il y a
pas autorisé un mariage on perd on va
bouleverser toute la filiation et une
nouvelle catastrophe on a nos petits
enfants qui vont la vivre
c'est sûr que c'est à 24h entassés je
pense que dans les années futures
ce jour là l'opposition se radicalise la
manifestation va se terminer par des
affrontements avec les forces de l'ordre
et des gaz lacrymogènes
le collectif la manif pour tous va se
laisser déborder par des éléments plus
radicaux
la contestation se durcit des agressions
homophobes se multiplient et le sénat
entame l'examen du texte jean pierre
michel reste serein et déterminé je suis
en état d'esprit de me dire ouf enfin
quoi voilà on est au ban de la
commission je ferme mon rapport et puis
après le dernier wagon s'est déroulé
pendant quelques jours au sénat et je
suis très heureux d'arriver à ce stade
de la procédure y aller dire voilà
la soeur s'est reprise l'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion du projet de loi
adopté par l'assemblée nationale ouvrant
le mariage aux couples de personnes de
même sexe et dans la discussion générale
la parole est à madame christiane
taubira garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice et la garde des sceaux qui vient
défendre le texte du gouvernement devant
les sénateurs
comme à son habitude elle va prononcer
un discours sans note pour nos 40
minutes
cette institution du mariage qui a été
une institution de propriété autant on
alliait sur tous les patrimoines qui a
été à une institution de domination du
temps où la loi ordonné obéissance à les
cous qui a été une institution de
possession du mari sur les phases sur la
femme et sur les enfants qui a été une
institution d'exclusion d'exclusion sur
la base de la religion d'exclusion sur
la base de la profession d'exclusion sur
la base des non croyance cette
institution est en train de devenir
universel sur ce projet de loi nous
avons peu de points d'accord mais nous
en avons un
il n'est pas anecdotique il est même
essentiel et comme vous l'avez si bien
indiqué cette réforme est vraiment une
réforme de civilisation c'est aussi ce
point de consensus ou me le pardonnerai
qui va finalement nous opposer de toute
la force de nos convictions et elles ne
sont pas de syed ni les vôtres
ni les nôtres nous partageons c'est vrai
cette idée qu avec ce texte il y à un
basculement vous soutenez que c'est un
progrès nous pensons que c'est un recul
vous avez commencé par rappeler un
argument qui a été beaucoup utilisé puis
il a fini par tomber un peu d'ici
l'étude j'allais dire à l'assemblée
nationale aussi sur la réforme de
civilisation je me réfère à la
civilisation au sens où aimé césaire
indique une civilisation qui ruse avec
ses principes est une civilisation
moribonde et je reprends donc cette
définition la france
oui la france s'est construite a
construit la nation la république c'est
république sur la passion de l'égalité
sur la passion de l'égalité
et oui nous nous réclamons de légalité
parce que c'est une valeur fondamentale
de la république et que ses lamas
particulière de l'histoire de la nation
française et de l'histoire des
république française
oui oui nous nous référons à cette
égalité est parce que nous nous référons
à cette valeur nous constatons qu
effectivement à diverses périodes il y à
ruse avec l'égalité il y ades prétexte
qu'on a parfois inscrit dans le droit
pour refuser à des citoyens la plénitude
de l'exercice de la citoyenneté et c'est
cela que nous corrigions
la solution le retrait ou le rejet nous
nous sommes les citoyens concept de nous
représentons des gens si tu préfères que
le gouvernement sauf eu de gros
problèmes de ce pays
voilà on arrive à tous du test c'est
qu'elle va comprendre alors que le sénat
va entrer dans le vif du sujet les pros
et les antis font monter la pression aux
abords du palais du luxembourg
nous aurons la mémoire longue renégats
basta vous dressant la liste de tous
ceux qui auront été les complices de ce
projet de loi quotidiennement pendant
sept jours
les opposants vont manifester aux portes
du sénat qu'ils nous prions pour que les
sénateurs vont devoir se prononcer dans
les jours qui viennent bien comprennent
la gravité de la décision vote qu'ils
prendront et bien nous demandons au bon
dieu nous demandons à la très sainte
vierge marie de bien vouloir orienter le
choix pour le seul qui soit bon c'est à
dire contre le projet du mariage
homosexuel
bien le respect bien leur est pas bon
sens on ne sait d'ici 2100 si sur le
fond des choses je crois que il y a un
vrai risque ici et c'est une autre forme
de violence que de changer le sens des
mots vous changer d'abord le sens des
mots sur le plan sémantique dans le
français aujourd'hui selon l'académie
française le mariage est l'union
légitime d'un homme et d'une femme vous
changer les mots le sens des mots je
veux redire que toutes les sciences
humaines et sociales montre bien entendu
le contraire et y compris l'académie
française elle même parce que si les
mots n'avaient aucun sens et que ce sens
était immuable
ce serait contraire à l'histoire des
langues à l'histoire tout court
vous savez que le dictionnaire de
l'académie française le plus récent
monsieur le premier ministre c'est le 9e
le premier date de 1694
si on a fait 9 dictionnaire de
l'académie française c'est que le sens
de beaucoup de mots a changé les mots
sont des êtres vivants oui c'est une
guerre de tranchées dans la mesure où
c'est un texte qui engage dans
conviction c'est un texte qui engage
beaucoup plus que ce que nous sommes
parce que et je crois que c'est aussi le
message qu'on comptait livrer les
millions de français qui ont défilé
depuis des mois et des mois
ça n'est pas un texte sur lequel nous
nous battons pour des droits des trois à
qui on se bat aussi pour les français de
demain c'est à dire pour une nouvelle
génération je suis favorable à ce texte
parce que je considère que moins l'état
l'examen de la loi se poursuit avec
l'adoption de l'article 1er qui institue
que le mariage est ouvert aux couples de
même sexe
les sénateurs de l'ump ont longtemps
bataillé pour plutôt offrir une union
civile aux couples homosexuels
un amendement présenté par le doyen
gélard qui est finalement rejetée d'un
revers de la main
la pression monte les quelques élus de
droite qui ont déclaré publiquement voté
en faveur du texte reçoivent des
insultes et des lettres anonymes
certains sont même dérangé chez eux au
petit matin c'est pas la violence qui
détermine un vote sont des valeurs et
des convictions et que le débat il se
fait ici donc qui manifestent ici c'est
normal les institutions démocratiques
c'est ici mais quand justement on se
réclame de la défense des droits de la
famille
il faut éviter de la violer jean pierre
michel elle lui aussi la cible des
opposants au mariage homosexuel
chaque jour il reçoit des dizaines de
courriers aujourd'hui on doit être un
millier de carte postale affranchie
donc c'est très bien ça donne de dire au
mieux la poste qui me sont envoyés et
qui me décerne le prix staline 2013 de
l'intolérance voilà donc c'est un
honneur évidemment
voilà on dit que j'ai dit que l'ipad
soit naturel puisque je pense que la loi
c'était rapport de force un certain
moment donné on le boit des majorités
parlementaires qui se crée qui font une
loi après ça quelques fois la loi et est
annulé des fêtes pas tout ça arrive et
qu'il ya un rapport de force politique à
un certain moment donné que ce rapport
de force
eh bien il en sort lui doit y compris
dans la société y compris
non
il y aurait les rétrogrades d'un côté
les progressistes de l'hôte
vous avez d'un côté l'idée d'une famille
idéale d'une famille idéale un papa une
maman deux enfants j'ai envie de vous
dire d'abord est ce que cette famille
idéale à exister une seule fois dans
l'histoire est ensuite même si cette
famille idéal existe aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la société est faite que ça
vous plaise que ça vous plaise pas et
que ça me plaise ou que ça ne me
plaisent pas et fait d'une diversité des
formes de famille et que vous pouvez
opposé effectivement une famille idéale
et que moi j'ai envie de vous opposer la
diversité des familles réelles
existantes aujourd'hui jean-pierre
michel profite d'une suspension de
séance pour aller à la rencontre des
partisans du projet de loi
il est accueilli en héros
vous êtes en train de changer la vie
d'une banque de fortune
non
non mais franchement je veux je veux
remercier nommément et malajube ira et
le gouvernement et caetera et merci
merci mille de voie pour comprendre
on va terminer le fait ce soir
dernier amendement dans l'hémicycle la
pression des antilles ne se relâche pas
jusque tard dans la nuit
ils continuent à manifester leur
opposition devant les grilles du palais
du luxembourg
le président de la république doit
entendre le peuple français
indépendamment des institutions du
parlement qui sur ce sujet ne
représentent pas l'opinion des français
voilà
le chers collègues je mets aux voix
l'ensemble du projet de loi ouvrant le
mariage aux couples de personnes de même
sexe ceux qui sont favorables pour
l'adopter lève la main merci ceux qui
sont contre
merci abstentions
mes chers collègues le sénat a adopté le
projet de loi ouvrant le mariage aux
couples de personnes de même sexe
finalement après sept jours de débats le
sénat vote le texte à main levée
aucun groupe politique n'ayant demandé
un scrutin public
la loi est adopté par 171 voix contre
165 y compris ceux du gouvernement pour
la qualité de vos interventions pour un
débat qui je le crois au nord le sénat
si monsieur le rapporteur de la
commission des lois
merci monsieur le président le ministre
besir collègues
bien sûr vous le comprendrez tout avec
beaucoup de fierté et d'émotion que je
savoure ce moment 15 ans après
l'adoption du pacs de faire en sorte que
je participe à une histoire qui n'est
pas fini vous l'avez tous dit non
l'histoire n'est pas finie elle se
poursuivra par des améliorations
constantes
parce que c'est ça notre société nous
ouvrons l'institution républicaine du
mariage aux couples de même sexe
la force et la puissance de la loi
consiste à énoncer des règles générales
qui puisse couvrir toute la diversité
des situations et anticiper sur la pop
l'excité des litiges et nous savons à
quel point l'imagination des hommes et
des femmes est infinie pour compliquer
les litiges notamment parce que en cas
de séparation
en cas de conflit le juge interviendra
le juge interviendra pour protéger le
membre du couple ou de la famille le
plus vulnérable plus fragiles il
interviendra pour veiller à l'intérêt
des enfants et je parle d'enfants oui je
parle d'enfants mais d'enfants d'enfants
qui vivent et qui existent de ses
enfants qui sont dans ces familles de
ces enfants qui sont faits de chair d'os
qui t'ont sont tous vivants de cris de
rire de ses enfants qui six corps chaud
genou de ses enfants qui aiment les
sucreries qui déteste les brocolis de
ses enfants qui nous explose la tête de
ces enfants là ce sont eux que vous
protéger à
ce texte de loire
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que même
des batailles on sait qu'on a le cuir
tanné on sait qu'on résiste à des tas de
choses et puis on est quand même super g
par l'émotion donc ça rappelle
simplement que ce que nous faisons à la
loi concernent des personnes voilà face
à la radicalisation des opposants le
gouvernement décide d'accélérer le
rythme
le texte est inscrit à l'ordre du jour
de l'assemblée nationale dès la semaine
suivante
la loi est adopté conforme c'est-à-dire
sans modification par les députés le 23
avril 2013
la procédure parlementaire arrive à son
terme
331 contre 225
après
après cent trente six heures et 46
minutes de débats l'assemblée nationale
a adopté le projet de loi ouvrant le
mariage aux couples de personnes de même
sexe
nous avons reconnu les droits de nos
concitoyens dont la citoyenneté
sournoisement contesté et nous avons
ouvert des droits à tous les autres
couples c'est donc incontestablement un
texte généreux que vous avez voté
aujourd'hui et nous en savons
définitivement gré mais l'opposition
n'entend pas en rester là
elle saisit le conseil constitutionnel
pour tenter d'invalider le texte
finalement les sages de la rue de
montpensier donnent leur feu vert
la loi est promulguée dans la foulée par
le président de la république
quelques jours plus tard à montpellier
bruno et vincent se disent oui devant
les caméras du monde entier unis
la france devient le quatorzième pays au
monde à autoriser le mariage homosexuel
où